How do I take ownership of mixed messages to the people under me from the other
leaders in my group?
Pretty straightforward question.
I like it.
Well,
first of all,
you have to address this straight up with the other leaders in your group
because if you aren't aligned as a leadership team,
this is going to hurt the cause.
It is absolutely going to hurt the cross.
This is critical and it's going to be hard.
And there are some things in your group that people do not agree on and that is
why they are undermining the messaging or why they're giving out different
messaging because they don't agree with it.
They don't have the courage to stand up and say,
Hey,
I don't agree with this right here,
so let's do it a different way.
Here's my thoughts.
They don't have the courage to do that.
So what do they do?
They just sit back and then when it comes time to put out the word,
they put out the mixed messages and it's,
it's a bad situation and you actually have to lead here.
That's what you have to do.
And it shouldn't actually be that hard because what you're asking for is
something that anybody can tell is important.
So you know,
you say this,
do you say to your leadership team,
you go,
hey guys,
our message to the troops needs to be aligned and right now it isn't.
We need to fix that.
Is there anyone on your leadership team's going to disagree with that?
No,
they won't.
That's not what they disagree with.
They,
everybody knows that the leadership team has to have an aligned message.
They have to be on the same sheet of music.
And that's what you need to do.
And,
and again,
it's going to be a hard conversation.
It's going to bring out that statement should bring out the conversation of what
people don't agree on and why they're sending miss messages.
Now
if you,
if you cannot get them aligned,
it is a serious problem.
But if you can't,
the best thing you can do is mitigate.
Mitigate that to your team by becoming the trusted voice.
So,
so with your team,
you want to become the trusted voice.
Now,
this doesn't mean that going gonna go on undermine your other leaders.
It's a,
I'll echo came in here.
He doesn't know what he's talking about.
No,
no,
no.
That's not what I'm talking about.
I'm never almost never talking about undermining another leader or a leadership
team.
What I'm going to do though is I'm going to translate,
I'm gonna say,
Hey guys,
our job on this,
I Know Echo said that.
Here's our job.
Here's,
here's what our focus needs to be.
Here's the way this translates for us,
so I'm not disparaging you and I'm not even disagreeing with you.
I'm simply honing the message from my team.
Now
you still,
even even when you do that,
you're mitigating that as much as possible.
You still have to maintain the critical goal of getting your leadership team
aligned and one other little tool to help make that happen is to present their
words back to them and you said,
you know what?
I wrote down what you said to the team this morning and I just wanted to go
through that with you and break it down a little bit and then go through it line
by line and have the hard conversations and make the tough decisions.
You've got to make the tough decisions
and also give a little.